after escaping the war in eastern
ukraine some of the injured arrive here
in lev on the western side of the
country to get much needed medical help
nina's virus lost her leg during an
attack on her village in the herson
region
i was together with my children they
went inside and i was outside and this
happened i couldn't call to my
daughter-in-law there were no windows
and doors everything was destroyed
fighting continues in eastern ukraine as
russia's military pushes to try to
secure control over the donbass region
but many civilians are paying the price
people here arrive with wounds that are
infected with shrapnel clothing among
other things some of the wounds are weak
sold
doctors here tell us that they're
desperate to get more antibiotics and
other medical supplies to treat those
who were injured
volunteer doctors like james henderson
are helping as best they can
same injuries he's using his annual
leave from the national health service
in the united kingdom to carry out
reconstructive surgeries mainly
civilians with horrible war injuries
from land mines gunshots shrapnel
blast injuries
our reconstructive techniques are very
difficult to do in this environment um
but we are managing you know essentially
the equipment they've got here is about
second world war um era
um and so we are using kind of
techniques that you would have been used
in those in those
seventy percent of patients do not
survive a limb injury and that's why
training doctors with new techniques is
crucial population
doctor
says he has been working non-stop since
the war started we're fighting with the
country that
don't separate the children the woman
the old man and the militaries the
strike to the civilian
infrastructure
to the school they destroyed more than
300 hospitals in the east and in the
center of ukraine
it's been almost six months since the
war began and those who are being
treated here are grateful to get a
second chance